hi everyone welcome to another episode
of science and technology q a for kids
and others i'm back in my usual
environment here
um and looks like we have some questions
saved up from a previous time
so let me try and look at a few of these
all right here's a slightly different
one from a toure
what do i think of psychological
personality tests and what type am i
so
interesting you know people are
different they react to the world
differently
how we come to be different is an
interesting question
that is probably a mixture of nature
sort of how we are constructed and our
genetics and nurture how we end up
growing up
and um
one of the things that
people have been doing for about a
hundred years now
is having these
kind of
tests where you say
answer these questions and then
characterize sort of what personality
type are you based on these questions
and so a really common one is the
myers-briggs tests which i think are
based on things from
psychologist
called carl jung from from sometime in
the in the early part of the 1900s
um
but in any case the um uh usually people
sort of characterize with these four
letters like i'm typically you know if i
do these things i'll typically be an
entj i'm not sure i can remember what
all the letters mean but the e
is extrovert so each each one of these
attributes there's one
uh there's two possible values you can
either be an extrovert or an introvert
and i'm afraid i can't necessarily
remember what the other ones are
um
but uh what does that mean
well you know there's some people like
kind of me who tend to in a situation i
will express myself i'll kind of be out
there you know talking to people
if i'm uh with people i don't know i'll
typically be hello let me
introduce myself type thing
that's kind of the typical extrovert
story the introvert story tends to be
more let me keep to myself
if you know if there's a situation where
it's like i could go and just say hello
i'm pleased to meet you type thing
versus i could just stay away and
wait for somebody else to come and say
hello to me that tends to be the
introvert type thing
and
so
it's kind of a question of what are you
really measuring what's really going on
in these situations well it's pretty
clear that different people have
different personality types
can we really characterize the
personality types that people have in
terms of let's say you know four letters
each with two possible values so that's
some uh you know 16 possible
overall personality type so to speak
does that really work are there really
16 kinds of people or is that just a
terribly coarse approximation and
perhaps even a misleading one
i don't think anybody knows
i think that
it's a little bit like
trying to characterize things like
emotions you know happy versus sad this
versus that
people have tried to make some
characterization of the kind of space of
possible emotions i was going to say
human emotions but i don't need to say
human emotions because we know it's a
famous work of charles darwin's actually
that
uh
dogs let's say
uh express how seem to have emotional
responses not completely different from
humans and they even you know they have
they they they do things equivalent to
smiles and growls and things with that
with their mouths that aren't that
different from what we humans do
and so the question then is is there a
sort of space of possible emotions uh
how how detailed is it and so on with
emotions we have some vague idea that
perhaps the levels of different
neurotransmitters in our brains are
related to different emotional states
and while in our brains there might be
you know
a hundred billion neurons that are all
doing different things it could be that
some characteristics of emotions are
more a feature of these kind of uh
sort of
these these chemicals that sort of wash
through our brains
to have an overall effect rather than
the detailed characteristics of of
individual neurons and so on
and it's conceivable that the different
neurotransmitters of which they're a
comparatively small number might have
something to do with these different
dimensions of sort of emotional response
it's not clear if that's correct when it
comes to personalities i think it's it's
you know one might wonder is it the case
that sort of personalities are
associated with some perhaps physical
aspect of the brain it used to be the
case a hundred years ago or more a
little bit more than 100 years ago there
was this strange
subject of phrenology
and the idea of phrenology was based on
the shape of somebody's head you could
tell aspects of that person's
personality now it's it's an interesting
thing because they're these kind of
ideas in science which at the time
everybody's like oh yeah of course this
is right and subsequently people are
like that was just a stupid idea how
could anybody have thought that that was
right
and and you would have these things
there would be these little models where
people
would you know a model of sort of a head
where you'd mark off the different
regions that corresponding to this or
that thing and
in the end it was a quite discredited uh
kind of uh concept
it's i'm not completely sure
what sort of scientific work was done to
fully discredit it but it sounds a bit
goofy at least
in any case the question would be if you
have different personality types um that
you could measure like extrovert versus
introvert or something which seems to be
a somewhat real thing because one knows
just from from sort of anecdotal
experience that there really are
different kinds of people with respect
to that i'm not sure that it's you're
either an extrovert or you're an
introvert it's more that's kind of a
scale and it might depend on which day
of the week it is which one of those you
were
any particular person is more into but
one can sort of imagine that that's a
thing now the question is if you've got
a brain you say is this an extrovert or
an introvert how would you tell
nobody knows right now
uh there's there's
the sort of the
so far as i know there's no known
correlate of these sort of personality
types that can be seen in kind of the
structure of the brain i'm not even sure
if so it's possible using
fmri functional machine magnetic
resonance imaging um a
technique where you're basically looking
at the amount of energy use in different
parts of the brain using using an
imaging device and so you can kind of
get this map of what part of the brain
is most active now and that's the thing
where lots of people have done lots of
experiments on you know when you are
doing this particular task what part of
the brain is most active when you are
thinking about this particular kind of
thing what part of the brain is most
active and i don't know of correlates of
that with these sort of personality
types and so on
so another question would be if you just
try and you know ask people questions
how do you respond in this situation are
you one of these people who prefers to
take charge of a group of people or you
prefer to be the person who's told what
to do are you a person who will uh uh
prefers to sort of uh invent your own
way of doing things versus some uh have
um uh follow what people say one should
do all these kinds of things you know
there's these kind of surveys you can
take
and a question would be if you do those
kinds of surveys
and you ask the question if you for any
given person they will answer certain
things in those surveys probably they'll
be fairly consistent i'm not sure how
consistent i think fairly consistent
probably over uh by the time they're
by the time they're teenagers too much
later that probably it's probably quite
consistent what people answer
um for any given person so you've
answered all these things and that sort
of puts you you say you're a person who
answered this this this this for all
these different questions and you can
say
in this sort of space of possible
personality types where does that put
you so in a sort of mathematical sense
let's say there are a hundred questions
and each one
has a whole scale of answers from from
zero to one let's say
that's like you have uh coordinates in
100 dimensional space
for where are you in this in this
hundred dimensional space where one of
the coordinate directions is introvert
extrovert another one might be um
uh i think one of these other ones is um
oh my gosh
uh
judgmental versus something else i'd
forgotten um but anyway so so is another
one of these sort of personality uh
parameters but but you could just almost
take it from the direct answers to the
questions um you could just say where do
you where do you you know what were your
answers to questions that puts you in
one point in the sort of question
answering space
now the question would be let's say you
take a billion people you ask them all
these questions
and you say you've got all these points
for all these different people and how
they answered and they're in different
places in this kind of space of answers
then the question would be
does that cluster in some way is it the
case that there are there are a whole
bunch of people who answer more or less
the same way over here and then there
are a whole separate bunch of people who
want some or else the same way over here
with big gaps in between with big places
where there aren't any people who answer
the questions in this combination of
ways it's always this combination or
that combination so that's the sort of
the question of what is the what's the
structure of the space of personalities
and i was curious about this at one
point actually i i am i almost had a
chance to to really study this because
um it was a company that was a large
dating site which had asked people oh
and aggregate billions of questions
and um
this was quite a number of years ago
when sort of machine learning was just
getting started and we had been talking
to them about using some machine
learning technology that we were
developing to just analyze this data and
to me that would have been an
interesting thing to look at
because
with these billions of answers you might
have been able to answer this question
is there a continuous range of sort of
personality types based on question
answering or are there clumps of
personality types if there were clumps
of personality types it makes it much
more seem like oh there's you know
people either have
this feature of their brain or that
feature of their brain not a continuous
variation between them i mean it's like
in our anatomy in general
the
people you know everybody is slightly
different with different heights we're
different uh you know we have different
ratios of lengths of fingers we have all
kinds of different um uh
different characteristics
and if you look kind of internally to us
there'll be people who have you know oh
there are two branches of this artery in
this place oh there are three branches
of this artery in this place and so on
we all have certain differences but some
of them are kind of discreet differences
like you either got the two artery
branch version or you've got the three
artery branch version and they're
definite different things and there
isn't like the two and a half artery
branch version and so one could imagine
that some similar things would be true
about brains brains are very very
diverse and that you know one might
think like fingerprints are a typical
way of of having something where
different people have somewhat different
fingerprints
fingerprints are formed by kind of a
folding process
during embryonic develop development uh
similar to a little bit to how ears are
formed and both of those
things
once you are folding differently you uh
you end up with in the end very
different looking fingerprints so to
speak
so
the uh the question is how different are
brains relative to fingerprints and the
answer is they're very different when if
you look at brains that they're just
their structure of sort of the folds and
ways that they're formed are just really
different from person to person
and so you know does that have an effect
is that the new phrenology i don't know
um people have been sort of collecting
um
collecting brains the collections aren't
really huge yet
um to to try and analyze things like
differences of the of these types
um
i think that uh
uh that's so
uh
there are there are still many mysteries
here and i think
um there's
this question of of kind of
are there
distinctly different personality types
or is it sort of a continuous range of
different kinds of responses to things
and also how much does it differ day to
day so to speak you know when you when
you fill out these tests of what would
you do in this situation what would you
in that situation well it may be
different from day to day and i don't
know how much variation there is along
those lines
so that's um
it's a little bit of response to to that
let's see
um
ah okay somebody's pointing out
that um
the entj classification the n stands for
intuitive
which intuitively starts with an n i
suppose the t stands for thinking and
the j stands for judging
okay
uh
and uh paul mendes is commenting entj is
the ceo personality type
hmm interesting see that's another
interesting question
is
uh given
you know if you look at different
activities that people have
how does that map into personality type
and which comes first the personality
type or the activity i mean it could be
that if for whatever reason you back
into being a ceo you end up being sort
of nurtured
into the ntj personality type let's say
or it could be that being the entj
personality type is what leads you to
even consider doing the ceo thing
because otherwise you'd um
uh
you know if you if you're very um you
know doing the ceo thing you know some
part of that is you've got to kind of be
in charge do leadership kinds of things
and and there are definitely personality
types where people are very
uh don't like that at all um i mean i
have to say i'm i tend to be of the
personality type as revealed by the the
entj nest i suppose that um the
personality type where if i'm in the
opposite situation where i'm being led i
don't like that at all so it's you know
different people have different um uh
different characteristics in that regard
so
um
let's see
let's see
so
common question here from ic about is
replication a necessary criterion for
the validation of a scientific
experiment
um well let's explain what that means
even
so
you know
one of the things when you report some
results in science
like you say i don't know
if i give you this vaccine it stops you
getting this disease
let's say
or
some more basic science result
about
i don't know
um something about
this particular
um
when when two black holes collide
they
uh
merge in this or that way
any of these results in science
the
the first sort of question is
can one tell
from can we do an experiment
to
answer the question of what happens when
i don't know let's pick another example
let's say if you've got
a um
uh
a plant that's growing this is a classic
experiment let me see if i can remember
how this works
um
you've got something like a a um
yeah okay let's do a really simple kind
of thing let's say how does the horn of
a rhinoceros grow
okay one possible answer is the end of
the horn just keeps getting longer
another possibility is at the at the
place where the horn attaches to the
head of the rhinoceros more horn is
added being added in that place
and so the question is which of these
things is actually true
and
so you might do an experiment you might
put a mark on the horn of the rhinoceros
and see how that mark moves as the horn
grows
that might be an example of an
experiment you might do
and so the question then is
well you could do that experiment on one
rhinoceros at one time and you might
discover this thing happened
and then you say but is it a repeatable
is it a reproducible experiment if i do
the same thing on another rhinoceros
will i get the same result or is it that
one rhinoceros grows at horn in this way
and another rhinoceros grows its horn in
that way and it's not a reproducible
experiment
um so a big thing and this is kind of a
kind of an idea from the early days of
of
thinking about doing science experiments
i mean it's worth saying that
historically in the development of
theoretical science
the idea of doing experiments
wasn't really
well formalized for a very long time i
mean
people i think thought when if you say
how does the world work
and people were thinking about that a
couple of thousand years ago in in
ancient greece or something like this
a lot of the answer to let's figure out
how the world works is let's just think
about it we can see various things
happening in the world now that we've
seen those things we've observed what
happens now let's just sit and think and
figure out why does that happen
and that's how we do it
now the idea that a rose particularly i
would say by the by the 1500s and 1600s
was this idea of no don't just sit back
and look at how the natural world works
and then start thinking through
why it does what it does instead do
experiments actually set things up and
say if i do this thing
then what will happen and if i do
another thing then what will happen and
deduce how the world works by doing
experiments that you've set up where you
say i want to see what happens if this
or that happens
okay so
some experiments
are
very easy to make reproducible let me
give an example that is
in uh
not about the natural world but about
the kind of computational mathematical
world
let's say you say something like
uh
well very very s
something like there's some this
particular number
is um
uh has this particular characteristic
you know you say 27 is three cubed
okay
well
that's
you know you might say that once but
it's it's trivial to reproduce that
experiment you can do the multiplication
again you can do it again you can do it
a different way you'll always get the
same answer it's trivially reproducible
the same is true if you set up some
computational rule and you have a
program and you
now in physics
there is
uh up to a point
a decent ability to have reproducible
experiments just because one imagines
one can set up the physical system has
sort of has cut and dried enough
characteristics you can really say i
want to make it exactly the same this
time versus the next time now there are
some some caveats to that for example
let's say you're dealing with something
where it matters you're dealing with a
gas the gas has molecules the molecules
are bouncing around in this seemingly
quite random way
which is associated with kind of that
and that the rate at which they're
bouncing around is associated with
temperature and heat and so on whenever
you have kind of lots and lots of
molecules bouncing around and and
implementing heat basically you have a
situation where
you in a typical experimental setting
you don't know where every molecule is
you just know in the aggregate they're
roughly like this and so that means when
you do the experiment it can matter that
the molecules in that particular time
you did that experiment were arranged in
exactly this or that way and so you get
this result and if they arrange
differently you get a different result
but that's not something you're
controlling in the setup of your
experiment
it gets even worse in quantum mechanics
in the theory of sort of individual
electrons and small particles and so on
because in quantum mechanics there is in
a sense a sort of fundamental randomness
to what happens we think we know now
from our fundamental theory of physics
that we've developed in the last couple
of years
a lot more about exactly why this
happens and how this works
but the the observed feature is that in
quantum mechanics there aren't definite
things that happen there are many
different possible things that can
happen and we when we observe how the
experiment came out with a certain
probability we get this result versus
that result so the idea of a
reproducible experiment in quantum
mechanics is just kind of out the window
because in quantum mechanics the way we
think it now works
is actually our universe has many
different possible branches of history
many different things can be happening
in the universe
and what is going on it's a little bit
of a brain twisting thing is the
universe is kind of branching into all
these possibilities so are our brains
branching into all these possibilities
and so the kind of issue is how does a
branching brain perceive a branching
universe
and it can happen in different ways
leading us to conclude that there's a
different result from any particular
measurement
and so but that process of kind of how
our brains sort of align with the
universe so to speak in making a
particular measurement
that process is not something we can
control for in our experiment and so
there is
in in some very theoretical sense there
is no reproducibility in quantum
mechanics because that is to get
reproducibility you have to control all
aspects of things and that aspect is
something that with the way that we
exist in the universe we are simply not
in a position to control
it is not self-evident that we are the
only way you can exist in the universe
and in fact
although i think it's a fundamental
feature of our kind of
consciousness and our kind of perception
of things like the fact that we have the
notion of a definite thread of
experience over time those features of
us which are pretty central to the way
that we work those features of us
force you into this situation like
quantum mechanics is at least for us not
perceived as reproducible and so that
means that the idea of reproducibility
in experiments as soon as we're dealing
with quantum mechanics basically the
existence of consciousness and a
definite threat of experience and so on
forces us to not have access to the
things we need to have access to in
order to make quantum experiments
reproducible now if you say
well how can you conclude anything about
quantum mechanics the answer is that
although you can't say what the outcome
of any particular quantum experiment
will be you might be able to say the
probability very accurately you might be
able to say exactly 60
of the time it will do this
and well what does that really mean that
means if you ran the experiment a
million times
roughly six hundred thousand times it
would do this but it isn't exactly six
hundred thousand times whenever you say
there's a certain probability of
something it just means on the average
in the long run that will be the
frequency of time something happens it
doesn't mean in any particular thing
that you do that you'll get that result
so
a a characteristic example of that is
coin tossing if you say you know if you
have a an unbiased coin half the time it
will come up heads half the time it will
come up tails but if you say uh you do
an actual experiment where you toss the
coin a bunch of times and you say well
what's the result you'd say well it
should be 50 50. 50 heads 50 tails but
any particular experiment you do it
won't be exactly 50 heads and 50 tails
it will have some sort of random walk
fluctuation around that value and so
sometimes
let's say you actually observe
that it was 70 heads after you did 100
experiments it came out 70 heads
you would say so then the question would
be
and assume that this coin was sort of
tossed randomly each time
well you would say what does it mean
that it came out 70 heads does that mean
that actually this coin is biased does
that mean we know for sure the coin is
biased or what does it really mean or is
that just bad luck and if we just kept
on flipping the coin more it would even
out and eventually it would be 50 50.
that's a complicated question that's a
sort of central question of statistics
this question of if you see that it is
70 heads what does it mean what does
that mean for for example the
probability that the coin is a biased
coin this all relates to a thing called
beza's theorem which is sort of a way of
backing out given what you saw what can
you tell about what was going on in the
in the model underneath
and the end result of of kind of
thinking about that is
it's it's ultimately you can't get
something for nothing and ultimately to
answer the question i just answered
about or just asked about what does that
mean for the coin
in the end you have to have an
underlying model for what possible coins
could be produced you can't answer the
question i just posed without knowing
something which is sort of a further
back issue which is imagine that you
have a lot of different coins what
fraction of them are biased in what way
if you can answer that
the so-called prior a priori uh kind of
um assumptions if you can answer that
then you can go from the observation oh
we saw 70 heads or something to what the
chance that the coin is biased would be
but you never get something for nothing
you always have to have some sort of
fundamental assumption down there but
any case so so one reason
that there can be science
even when an indefinite quantitative
results that are these kinds of results
that say with probability x such and
such will happen but that's not going to
be a perfectly reproducible experiment
that's going to be an experiment that is
somehow statistically reproducible
okay now here's where things get really
difficult
when you go into for example biology and
you say can you make a reproducible
experiment in biology well that gets
quite difficult because
you know every
every time you do the experiment you
know every mouse
has a slightly different state you know
even if and people
do this a lot to breed genetically
identical mice that they keep in these
giant very automated mouse colonies for
for in labs and so on they they breed
these mice that are genetically
identical but even genetically identical
mice aren't absolutely identical it
depends what did the mouse do that day
did the mouse eat this did the mouse do
that
it's never precisely controllable how
things work
and
so that makes it much more difficult to
do biology experiments and to know you
know you say well i did this on 10 mice
and i got the same result each time and
then i do it on 11th mouse
and oh by it's different
what happened
well
it if sometimes if you can figure it out
you can say well the reason it was
different is because that mouse was
older than the other mice or the reason
it was different is because that mouse
had gone through this maze the day
before and done this or something
um but it's very hard usually to figure
out what it was that was different and
this fights one incredibly strongly in
medicine
because you know us humans are not all
genetically identical and unless we
happen to have identical twins or
something
and we have many differences both in our
genetics
and in our uh you know what have we
eaten all of our life what exercise we
take in all of our life what experiences
we had all of our life we have lots of
differences and so when you say we're
going to test this particular medicine
on people and say does it work does it
not work
well it might depend on a lot of things
and teasing out for example the the the
sort of the definitive science question
does it work
is a really hard thing to answer because
the answer might be well it works with
people who have this characteristic and
that characteristic but not this
characteristic and there are so many
characteristics that people might or
might not have that it's really
difficult to do that experiment you
might have to i mean i suppose that in
things like the vaccines that are going
on right now there's literally billions
of people getting these vaccines and so
those are have the capability to be
in a sense as good by biology
experiments as pretty much you'll ever
get i mean you can do experiments on at
the level of cells where you can
probably sample even more cells than we
have humans sampled in this particular
case
but the you know the question will be
well what can you actually conclude you
know how does this work and that work
and so on and the answer tends to be
it's really quite complicated and the
notion of a pure outright it's a
reproducible experiment
is not so much of a thing and it's a
difficult thing because for example
let's give an example of how this
impacts the world at large
so
if you're going to say
there's a drug
some drug company has produced it you're
going to say is this a good drug or not
so then what you do
is the the basic standard of how that's
figured out these days is to do a
clinical trial you say we're going to
give some people a drug we're going to
give some people not knowing that they
didn't get the drug we're going to give
them a placebo where they they they
might have got the drug but they didn't
actually get the drug we're going to
have these two different groups of
people and we're going to see did the
drug do really good things for people
who got it and did nothing interesting
happen for the people who didn't get it
and if the answer is the drug did really
well for the people who got it
and uh the things that that did well for
the people who got the drug didn't
happen for the people who got the
placebo and the people who got the drug
didn't have some horrible side effect
and so on then we say great we've got a
drug that works now go feed it to
another billion people
okay so now the problem is what tends to
happen
is that well it works on some people it
doesn't work on other people it has side
effects for some people it doesn't have
them for other people okay what do we
conclude one thing we might conclude is
as soon as anything goes wrong we might
say forget it we're out of here this
drug is a failure and unfortunately that
happens a lot
but the truth of the situation is a
little bit more of the reproducibility
of experiments question it is probably
the case that the people if the drug
worked on some people but failed on
others gave side effects on others
that really there's different
characteristics of those people it's not
just pure chance that oh well you know
it so happened that this happens just
chance it's it's undoubtedly not chance
it's undoubtedly because the person who
had the side effect is a person who has
a different uh you know slightly
different version of this enzyme that
came from their genetics that blah blah
blah blah blah whatever else
but the question is can you tease that
out can you figure out that there's that
kind of thing and one of the things
people hope is that in the future there
will be a much more personalized version
of medicine where perhaps this
particular drug with this particular
particular molecule with a particular
shape and so on it'll be like well for
you we need a modified version of that
molecule that has this extra few atoms
in this place because the place it's
going to bind inside your body is
you know is for genetic reasons has a
slightly different configuration so we
need to give you this sort of
personalized changed molecule for this
drug now the question is if you say well
we're going to test you know for drugs
to be okay we're just going to test them
using this on off it works it doesn't
work kind of approach that's a very
difficult thing to do if everybody gets
a custom version of a drug um and quite
how that's going to be worked through
because obviously one doesn't want to
just say oh just do whatever you want
it's you know because all sorts of
terrible things will happen um but then
the question is how do you essentially
validate a
a um a whole kind of algorithm for
producing drugs or even more than that
if the drugs themselves are molecules
which when they go into your body
actually start algorithmically as a
molecule doing computations and
reconfiguring themselves and so on it's
like you know the the molecule goes in
as a generic molecule but when it's
inside you when it detects that there's
some particular kind of cell it modifies
in this way and so on and so on and so
on how do you validate
that that all the right things are going
to happen
and uh to some extent issues like that
have been addressed in medical devices a
bit but not completely um and i think
that's a sort of a challenging thing and
it would be a real real shame if a lot
of things that would be super helpful
medically just can't be done because
nobody can figure out the kind of
reproducibility of experiment story in a
way that that everybody's happy with um
for for those kinds of um uh
for those kinds of things
let's see
um
oh this is some coming back to um
uh
earlier question here about personality
types from a toray wondering if
personalities are clustered and
wondering if their data sets available
on this uh the data set that we
uh sort of almost had access to
from this uh dating site i think was
sort of the biggest one at the time that
was really the biggest realistic such
data set
um
uh and i i think that's the kind of
place such data sets would have been
collected
is um uh is those kinds of places
um
let's see
ah
oh boy
um
there's a question here about um from
slayer
i'm afraid
uh about a
a weird medical phenomenon a chap called
phineas gage who had a very unfortunate
accident that caused a giant rod to get
um
go through his his brain
and um uh i don't know all the all the
um
characteristics of what happened you
know one of the general principles about
medicine
is
you know you think there's a kind of cut
and dried answer to something you know
if you destroy this part of the brain
it's all over or something and then you
find oh but there's an exception here's
a person who survived this particular
thing well here's a person where
this
characteristic just worked in a
different way with respect to the brain
and one of the big questions about the
brain
is
if you
sort of look at a brain it has a
complicated structure you know you can
just see it has a complicated structure
but also each different part of the
brain is quite specialized in what it
does you know there's a piece that that
is controlling you know there's a
there's a definite area that controls
the muscles in your you know left index
finger or something there's a definite
area that controls you know kind of the
um uh what you see in this part of your
visual field and how you do the first
levels of a vision from this part of
your visual field there's a definite
part of your brain that is associated
with for example language
well one of the things that happens is
some things are in pretty fixed
locations
uh like the things to do with movement
the things to recite they're in pretty
fixed locations the things like how you
understand language that look at that
moves around a bit between different
people
but there's sort of a big question of
to what extent is the brain retargetable
and what it does that is if
you if some part of your brain
fails in some way you know let's say you
have a a stroke and that part of your
brain is deprived of oxygen and those
cells die or you have some nasty
concussion and you kind of tear apart a
bunch of nerve nerve cells and so on all
definitely bad things to do
but um uh you know when when that
happens is it the case that some other
part of the brain can kind of come in
and take over the functions that were
being done by the part of the brain that
was damaged
and
the answer seems to be well to some
extent yes
uh particularly if it happens
you know if the damage occurs when one's
very young then it is it is often the
case that one can
sort of have other parts of the brain
come in and
uh take over those functions and
all is good so to speak it's sort of
interesting that that's possible because
there's sort of the question of
one might have thought a brain is a
catholic sort of controlled machine
where every piece does a definite thing
and each piece is necessary for some
aspect of how we operate
but the kind of the big thing that was
discovered that's sort of the foundation
of the idea of software for computers is
that you can have a device like a
computer which when you just feed a
different software it will do all these
different kinds of computations it will
do all these different kinds of things
and so you might imagine that brains are
a little bit the same idea that is that
there's a fixed hardware all of those
hundred billion neurons and so on but
that depending on the software depending
on what actual memories are in the brain
and so on that you can have the brain do
different kinds of things and i think
that it tends to look as if
uh in many respects
the brain
can be sort of rearranged and like this
thing that was really most often does
this for in people
can be made to do that in people instead
clearly when people have different
senses like for example they you know
they they don't have good vision for
example they don't have good hearing
those parts of the brain that were
responsible for vision or hearing um end
up being you can use those neurons for
something else
and so a quite common experience is
people who have difficulty with one of
those senses the other senses become
more acute and probably more neurons
are recruited to to make use of those
things than them would be otherwise
um so
so that's um uh so i mean i think this
question of just how retargetable at
different parts of the brain is an
interesting one and i don't think one
really knows the full answer to that um
there will be other aspects of that
question which will come in when we have
um
if we have when we have sort of better
direct connections to the brain you know
the brain is an electrical device in
effect where all these neurons are
producing electrical signals that
they're transmitting to the neurons that
they're next to and all those kinds of
things and so one of the questions is
can we just connect into that electrical
network and just wires things into our
brains
well that's something that's done as a
sort of medical clinical thing
particularly in the case of parkinson's
disease
um
where
the um i guess it's dopamine uh one of
the neurotransmitters
is does not get produced as much as it
normally would by the cells that
normally produce it
and one of the ways to kind of fix
things is to actually have a a
stimulator that is a a an electrical
device implanted in the brain
that uh and and so that that's a rather
coarse example and there are similar
examples in things related to epilepsy
where there's sort of a a let's
recontrol what the brain does by feeding
it electrical signals that will
potentially uh divert what it was
otherwise going to do now one can
imagine a much finer version of that and
people do lots of experiments on this
trying to get something that's like like
the technology microprocessors sort of
directly with all those detailed little
wires and things being able to directly
connect to neurons in the brain and be
able to sort of monitor for example have
a raise of of
electrodes that kind of monitor what's
happening in many different neurons in
the brain
one day we might be able to kind of pick
up the kind of internal communications
between neurons and the brain uh it will
be not easy to decode that i mean the
thing that's probably the more immediate
thing in which i think there's been some
success on
is uh things like in the spinal cord
where one's using the
bundle of nerves that control
uh you know all of one's movements and
and so on um
a question of come one come on have an
electrical device that is just sort of
sees all of those nerve endings and can
figure out which nerve is doing what and
can produce its own version of that
stimulation and there's some degree of
success nowadays with that kind of thing
but i think that the um the question is
if we were able to pick up if we were to
monitor a very fine level what's
happening in all those electrical
communications inside the brain could we
figure out what those communications are
about and if we were able to feed in new
things could we like
let our brains directly do arithmetic
for us without not rather than
arithmetic being done by our neurons say
well i'm just thinking about what is uh
13 times 39 or something and just by
thinking about it it would kind of the
the electrical connections would be
you those thoughts would be decodable
and then you could just go off and ask
your computer to do that computation and
feedback the results
that's sort of a challenging question to
can we sort of can we can we detect that
internal communication in the brain
understand it and go back and and and
put something else in now now the thing
to understand is that brains
the communication between brains doesn't
seem to be such a simple matter human
language is the main way we have to
communicate between brains
and in a sense what's happening is you
know as i'm yakking away here no doubt
you know
a billion neurons in my brain are doing
all kinds of nerve firings and sending
all kinds of electrical signals and so
on and the result is that i say fool or
whatever and the then for you to hear
that word then that causes a bunch of
nerve firings in your brain and then
that causes you to have certain thoughts
within your brain that are based on
other thoughts you've had and other
things you remember and so on and it's
kind of in the in the computer sense
it's sort of the api that we have
between brains the way of communicating
brain to brain is human language and
we're sort of putting it into that we're
taking the inner thoughts that we have
which involve nerve firings of billions
of neurons and so on and we're arranging
those into this thing with is this
essentially api this communication
channel that we're able to communicate
to another brain
and the question is is there a direct
kind of brain to brain or or brain to
machine kind of interface where you're
not turning everything into this whole
elaborate language you're just looking
at the level of kind of the individual
nerve firings and so on
a slightly cautionary tale is what would
happen with computers
if i opened up my computer and i put
little wires and probes in different
places in its cpu and i said what's
going on here it'd be pretty hard to
tell
you know back in the day
i have to say i haven't tried this in
years but back a long time ago like like
uh 30 40 years ago
if you took a radio a standard kind of
am radio and you put it next to a
computer
and the computer was doing things the
radio would go crazy because there are
all these electromagnetic emissions from
the electrical activity in the computer
and you'd be essentially hearing some
version of what the computer is doing
but what you'd heard
you know with all the squawks and
squeaks and this and that and the other
it's very hard to decode
it's very much and if you get down to
the level of there's individual wires
and there's individual values in this
register in the cpu et cetera et cetera
et cetera decoding what's going on
reverse engineering what's going on from
that very low level representation is is
pretty difficult and that's what we're
kind of signing up for if we say well
we're going to take what happens in the
brain and look at these individual nerve
firings and so on and see what they mean
now it turns out machine learning which
is kind of an idealized version of how
brains work is probably one of the best
shots we've got at going in and looking
at these detailed oh there's this
particular set of no firings what does
it mean
um that machine learning is basically
well here are some examples of what it
means then machine learning can kind of
extrapolate from that and say so in this
different case that i'm seeing now this
is what it means here so that's probably
our best hope for being able to sort of
decode the inner language of
of of brains even though there might not
be we don't know to what extent there is
in a language we don't know whether
there's a level in between
the me talking to you in english type
thing and the level of individual
neurons firing and doing what they do we
don't know if there's some way that
there is a sort of an intermediate
language where it's like not as
beautifully formed as english but not as
just write down the level of individual
bits of the individual nerve firings
it's a it's a sort of
an interesting and fundamental challenge
for neuroscience is to figure out is
there such an intermediate language we
don't know the answer yet
let's see
uh
well it's a question here from prath
prathamesh
asking about ai politics and decisions
gosh
i'm not sure there's many different
aspects to that that um
uh
that
those words
one of the things that um
we might wonder about
is
when we set up machines
and the machines kind of in some sense
decide what to do
how do we feel about that
so
at some level
we
we have certain devices we build
and sometimes we can readily understand
we built this device we move this lever
in this way
the device is going to engage this wheel
in this way and it's going to move in
this way and we can kind of see what's
going to happen and we kind of know we
set this device up we pull this lever we
know what's going to happen if you pull
the lever you know what's going to
happen you're responsible for what
happens if you pull that lever
all quite straightforward now let's
imagine that in that loop is this
complicated ai system that has all these
things where it's a it's a self-driving
car and it's figuring out based on some
very complicated algorithm and this and
that and the other is it going to
swerve when it sees a a deer jump into
the road or not and is it going to
swerve and if it swerves does it swerve
into another car and how does that all
work
and who is responsible for what goes on
there now one of the things you might
say is well whoever wrote the program
they're responsible for what goes on
there but that's not a realistic thing
to say
because we know
that i mean my own work actually in this
area is is
kind of makes it clear that there's this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that is you write a
program the program specifies rules but
when you run those rules and you run the
millions billions of times or whatever
to know what consequences that will have
is not something that you can foresee in
advance you just have to run it and see
what happens
so you can't just sort of say well i'm
going to make sure
that my device never does the wrong
thing look i'm going to tweak this piece
of code to make sure it never does the
wrong thing that's not realistic because
knowing what it will do there's this
irreducible amount of computation that
is involved in figuring out what it does
in any particular case and that's not
something where you can just say i'm
going to guarantee it's going to do
nothing bad the next question is what do
you even mean by nothing bad
what do you mean in a situation where
you say
um you know is this thing going to
successfully
shut down this uh giant motor or
something well that's a very
well-defined objective and you can say
did you succeed did you not succeed
if the question is did this
uh self-driving car ever do the wrong
thing
ever do something you didn't want it to
do that's a much more complicated
question
let's take an example that's a very
fraught question which is autonomous
weapons so you've got some drone running
around and the drone has a gun and the
gun can shoot at things and the question
is under what circumstances should the
the drone shoot at something
and it's like you say well i've got
certain rules i don't want to do it in
this case i do want to do it in this
case
but it's
it's impossible to specify
with
all different eventualities of what
could happen
what if
the um
i don't know
you know
what if you say
uh
leave the animals alone this is a
problem between humans but yet you have
the trained killer pigeon or something
you know what do you do in that case
the um
it's uh uh and all these different
things where a human might say well
based on my whole story of judgment of
this and that and the other i decide to
do this but this ai system has been set
up with certain principles and so on and
it's but it's not
uh
well one of the worst cases is let's say
the ai system is just learnt by from
examples let's say it had a thousand
examples of what to do and then it's out
in the wild and it's told just go do the
right thing based on those thousand
examples the problem is the thing that
happens out in the wild may be so
different from any of those examples it
has no idea what to do
and sometimes you don't even know it has
no idea what to do because it just
learnt from those examples and it built
up some whole sort of machine learning
sort of idea of what to do
and it didn't um and you don't know that
it doesn't know and he it doesn't know
that it doesn't know um because it just
follows the principles that it's been
operating according to
and it just it ends up that well
actually if there'd been this critical
extra example given it would have done
the right thing but there wasn't and it
didn't know that there was a hole there
and you didn't know there was a hole
there now i tend to think that a better
approach
is
computational contracts effectively for
for devices what does that mean that
means something where just like you
would like to write a legal contract
where you write out in english or some
other language or some kind of legalese
this is what i want to have happen in a
way where where
both
sides both parties can read the document
and say yes we think we know what this
means we think we understand it and
therefore we can follow it
in the case of machine learning for
example where you just say let's learn
by example you don't really have that
situation at least not as directly
you are much better shape if you say
well i'm going to write this
computational language that is a thing
that i can read and i understand what it
says and okay now ai go follow this
principle that's a better situation to
be in now of course you have to have a
language that can express the kinds of
concepts that are relevant for telling
the ai do the right thing that's
something that actually in in our
technology development over the last uh
35 years or so on um we've we've come a
long way to having kind of a computer
full-scale computational language that
can kind of express
all these different kinds of things in
the world and ideas about what should
happen in the world and so on and so i
think that's a sort of a good direction
for that
um
but uh
um
it's uh
let's see i think that um
um
uh
well let's see parmenides is commenting
how crazy would it be if politics
becomes like hedging where it's all run
by algorithms vote for algorithm one for
posterity algorithm three is tough on
crime etc etc etc
yeah well
you know
that's kind of what i'm sure that's
basically what's going to happen i mean
in a sense that's the story of democracy
you know you say you might say
uh you know vote for party x
you know
but in a sense you're voting for the
algorithm of party x
you're voting for whatever
you know or you might say well i'm
voting for the character of of party x
but in a sense
it's not as cut-and-dried as there's
this computational contract and this is
what you're voting for it's more you
you're you're kind of prox you're saying
i want things to be run according to the
procedure that is associated with party
x or person y or whatever else
and so in a sense that's what's
happening except it's not implemented
it's implemented with a human system
rather than a computational system
now the question is what happens if it
is a computational system what happens
if for example you say i'm voting for
this
computational contract okay here it is
it's
uh you know it's 50 pages long it is the
description of what i want to have
happen in the world how i want
the country to be governed or whatever
else it is and it is like a constitution
like the one that a country like the us
and many countries in the world have a
constitution which is sort of supposed
to be the foundation for kind of how the
country is is governed um but in this
case rather than it being just a
foundation it's interpreted and it's got
millions of pages of legal opinions and
things that are have been added to that
sort of underlying set of principles
that instead you say well no
actually it's just going to be this
piece of code and that's it and that's
what decides what happens and you know
people will say well i don't like that
piece of code and maybe they have some
democratic process where they say we're
voting out that piece of code we want
this piece of code instead and people
would argue you know they would draft a
new piece of code and people would spend
a long time kind of developing you know
what what is that let's put an addendum
to this piece of code that deals with
this complicated situation and what
happens if this etc etc cetera and then
there might be three variants of it and
people might vote we want this variant
versus this variant and so on but it's
all in the sense code
um
is that a good situation well is that is
that a situation that can and will
happen i'm sure it will happen
um and whether it happens in that rather
transparent form or whether it happens
in a much less transparent form where
it's like i vote for this
and where this is a human system and
that human system writes the code
and then you're stuck with what the code
does but the the point about code making
decisions that's inevitable and that's
already happening to a large extent i
mean basically what
you know when decisions have to be made
quickly or in bulk whatever else
it makes
it is completely impractical for humans
to make those decisions whether it's
in
let's say in financial trading kinds of
things you know should i buy this should
i sell this oh i'm doing it a thousand
times a second well no human is going to
be able to do that or i i'm taking in
all of these signals for what i might
buy and sell
just like one might imagine
a lot of the kind of controls that
governments have
are
you know that they're comparatively
coarse it's like what are we going to do
with interest rates what are we going to
do with money supply
these are levers that you turn they
don't get turned you know it's not like
it's not like an airplane flying where
you see those little um uh
things at the back of the wings that
flap up and down automatically
controlled by a control system to try to
keep the airplane flying in a level
flight or whatever you know it's not the
case
that in the financial system at least in
the government financial system that
there's a similar kind of rapid control
system where something is kind of
flapping you know every day doing this
or that at least not that i can think of
that certainly happens in the private
sector of finance but it does not happen
in the public sector of finance i
believe um and one can imagine a
situation where where people say well
actually we want that to happen install
you know at the central bank install
this algorithm basically install this
computational contract that's going to
determine what the interest rates are
reset every second or something
well
uh you know
in those kinds of things you can have a
local version of that or you can have
something more global where you say this
is the overall set of things we're
trying to achieve now optimize these
thousand parameters we'd never specify
all those thousand parameters separately
but you can say you know you you're
setting up oh i don't know tariffs on
this these goods and and this particular
tax on this thing and this particular
whatever those are the current controls
of government um and uh you know i i
happen to be a the less controls there
are from government the better but
that's just a personal preference um the
uh
uh i think that um uh it's something and
and um no doubt
um
but but uh uh it's something where where
um you can you can kind of ask um maybe
that goes with the entj personality type
i don't know um but uh uh that's another
interesting issue is let's say you have
a situation where
you uh that's a that's a bizarre
possibility
um you know you've got something where
you sort of are interacting between you
know people with all their complicated
preferences and all of their um
the um uh
um
the uh
um
um
uh with them
uh
yeah it's um it's it's it's complicated
i'm getting a note here that reminds me
i'm late for something and it notes that
it's a it's a meeting with an isp fp
which is apparently the exact opposite
of an entj
so uh so so it goes um all right maybe
maybe um uh
um
maybe i'll i'll
um do just there's there's lots more to
say about um
uh about kind of um
the the interaction of ai with politics
with this and that um i i'm not a person
who knows much about politics as such
but but um
the um uh the thing that i think is kind
of the the challenge
is in a situation where it is possible
to have a finer delegation
of
things than just saying i vote for party
x
where you can specify things in more
detail with computational contracts and
so on what does that mean and do you end
up with does every person effectively
have their own political party where
they say i
i declare that i want the country to be
run according to this computational
contract i wrote it i started writing it
in grade school i kept on adjusting it
my whole life and this is my contract
this is what i want the world to be like
and now at the age of 40 or something my
contract is 8 000 lines long and it's
got all this complicated cases for this
and then the other this is what i want
the world to be like
and you then imagine the situation where
okay you collect everybody's you know
preferences and you put them all into
some big machine and you say okay now
figure out what to do because
unfortunately
it is the nature of society in the world
and the physicality of the world and so
on that uh you know it's not possible to
give everybody everything that they want
um and because sort of everybody has to
live in the same space so to speak and
interact and so on and so then the
question is how do you optimize given
all these different preferences that
came in how do you come up with the
optimum and it's a little bit like what
i was saying before with statistics that
in the end there has to be a base base
base base based set of assumptions
without that you really can't resolve
that question
and and even with that
it's like for example a very obvious
question is
if
there are things that will make 80 of
the world really happy and 20 really
unhappy
and whereas there are other things that
will make
uh
60 you know 50 percent of the no will
make everybody reasonably happy what is
the trade-off between making 80 really
really happy and 20 really unhappy
versus everybody's kind of happy but not
as happy as they would have been and not
as unhappy as they would have been which
of those is the better world
which of those do you want to have
happen now people might put that very
statement into their computational
contracts this is what we want
for for that balancing of things but
that's a very complicated infinite
regress and and there won't be a
resolution unless you somehow at the
bottom of it say this is what globally
we decide wants to have happen
and you know i think that's a
it's a it's a feature i suppose i'm sure
that there are echoes of this throughout
the history of political philosophy
and in a sense we're pretty lucky that
the world is set up so that it has for
example multiple countries where
different things can be done different
sort of core assumptions can be made
and i think it's some so i mean
and then there's the whole question
which is which again turns into all
kinds of complicated politics about you
know in in the world of the future let's
imagine that we're all uploaded to some
giant digital
thing and we don't have to worry about
the physicality of do we move from
country x to country y physically in the
physical world it's all digital and just
by merely sort of a a puff of electrons
we could be transported into a different
into a different environment um
you know how then
would uh you know would you just say to
people well just go to where you want to
be
of course that doesn't work either
because it could be the case that um uh
you know you end up in a situation where
where
the world has to be maintained in some
sense and everybody wants to do this
everybody wants to be
a um
i don't know
everybody wants to be a painter
and nobody wants to make the trains run
well that's not good
now again in some sort of sense of some
sort of digital utopian something or
other where where there is no
physicality there are no trains to be
running maybe you can maybe there's a
way to deal with that or even then i
suspect it isn't the case i suspect it's
sort of inevitably the case that if
everybody wants to paint and nobody
wants to make the trains run
then uh that's not a good situation and
then what do you do with that
and and you're you're thrust back into
the same kind of complicated morass
that um that is the sort of the
long-term history of political
philosophy
right well that gets me into um uh
um
um
yeah there are all kinds of interesting
questions here which i haven't had a
chance to address this time but that's
okay because there'll be another time
next week um and uh should wrap up here
for now and i look forward to um
uh
seeing you again
well
i wish i could see you all
but uh at least um
um
in some sense being with you all same
time next week
all right thanks very much and uh bye
for now